за цієї нитки я до його нічого вилікую в про
україну
мабуть вже нереально ти відразу милу а
джон станемо у мене тема
українська щури відразу я став екраном
photos піднімати до газет я скажу на заході
і ми знову і на ходу від кого нічого на
вважаю вона під і куди ще слухаю радіо
потрібен упокоїти інформація про на пружину
ситуацію їх там сир і такого пазла до
виживають світ не люди мовчання яскравим і
столичним дозам в будинок переважно belle
частина німці нині виступають прохання
дикову кровопролиття доставить рушимо
як став моя хата з краю
нічого не знаю далеко вид нас
даровані мажу одне водила завжди
знаходяться такі ось він він і проби поза
людовіку не захищені ви знають рахунок риба
каже та однорідним up in та глибини
зараз майдану пара важливо їжі знімемося в
Петро йому вала євроінтеграції неправдами
українців однак зближення українців з
за стріла жорсткої опер русі і обернувся
глибокий міжнародний щур я гнатися
довіряти про перетин німці
євроінтеграції не про нами українців
громадян і відразу однозначно Петро
янович
українці хоче вступити їжу і з того мій
підписав і відведення про асоціацію а взяти
акри за ви на квартиль, бо путін
не хочеш і українців і відпустки
russian am ch їй вікна та підходи до
україна за чекай було в зоні в Росії та
ми не можемо включати звідти віджиму
затискання стегна це для тіней категорії не
integrity розумінням ставити адаб
равликів і путіна в не менше не на відео
ви всі спеціальний термін
путін форш т р в іншу бенкетує зазвучав
одним їжі нам аргументом сварки тис з
руси юн і можна ось за skoda
економічним інтересам берліну
російська пропаганда де
і за машиною у вигляді кого можна слово в
слово порчу тир це руку російських змі
україні там
всі суре посади та міністерські всю каву
і спецслужби переконав її нацисти націй так
їх радикальних улучів нині є 2
кратний німців теж усі колишні на
адже довіряє русі 190 зовсім
у саші поважають за не активні і дали виступ
ідеалів smooth quoil на передній план
виходить роль немечений і від посередника
у того ж посередництво добра роль для
не мачин і
на мою думку мінімуму петром його thecus
один бік але покритий романам агати
сядуть прямого тис. нейтралітет у звіряю
чого б дві сторони конфлікту до діалогу
цим порізати інсів повернулася на великі
європейські країни
на по ви не завищувати гострий накида до
бухти українцям а віку і виріж у
цій ситуації все таке самі та українці
я крим найбільш пшоном не міченому лобода
пункти україні націлив можна тупо macht
та фінансово
наскільки я знаю раніше фінансово
допомогу українці надавала росія та нами
політ означає ну краш тексту закинь
екрані наташ підключається до
фінансування c так допоможе українцям з
менше ти вплив росії і рука тис на
премку заходу 100 тобто на заклали на
обличчя на павіан від я хочу це допомагати і
туфельки на весь кову ми німці спраги
проходимо і треба папір меншим краї нам
і українцям те, що ми можемо навіть
заплановано і так і буду з голоду many
common та будинки по martin спа на 3 десятки
у перехожих зеками ми оскільки волосся
на в променях боно про важливість біс вислали
вала свою пит ринку українцям у team так
не досвід іван лише вдвічі we do
лагуна шкіра не мати з розумінням ставите
до того ще негайно
фінансово-економічну мер
розплачуватися за українсько-російську
конфлікт